it was only four days ago that president
biden assured the american people of
this
if you take a look at the number of
people are coming
we're sending back the vast majority of
the families that are coming
vast majority of the families really
according to his own border patrol
however all that data the bide
administration
expelled just 41 of the families
entering our country illegally
joining me now is julio rosas
townhall.com senior writer
joins us from the front lines in the
border crisis in mcallen texas
julio you're saying that what there's a
common
theme to where these folks are or
flooding in or a common characteristic
explain
that so in this one area
of la jolla texas about 20 minutes from
where i am right now
there was the border wall system that
was being built under president trump
that was being built in that area in la
jolla but obviously it has since been
stopped because the buy administration
has put that to a pause and so that's
why in that specific area there's just
miles of open space
and because there's no border wall
system because there's no barrier it is
very easy
for family units for unaccompanied
minors and small children
as we saw last night about 120 uh just
cross
uh over there day in and day out in fact
some of my friends were out there just
this afternoon and they saw about 30 and
so
that's why it's very easy for small
mothers carrying small children to cross
just simply because there's
no barrier there yeah and julio the
arizona republic is reporting that
starting in february
border agents began releasing migrant
families under this
thing called humanitarian parole and
what happens is that
agents basically just drop them at bus
stops
in these smaller you know farming cities
like yuma
and then they started releasing entire
families over the past week
in some of these other small communities
um forcing these local governments
to declare an emergency are you
are you hearing the same thing or you're
witnessing any of this
well what i can say is that in these
border towns they definitely
feel the strain because there are people
in brownsville when i was here
about three weeks ago i saw uh migrants
being dropped off
uh that were family units at the
greyhound bus station there and so there
were local charities helping them out
uh but no the the this the the border
towns are the first to feel the effects
of this
of this search but the thing that's
important to note is that they're not
staying in places like brownsville
mcallen or laredo there
are going further into the united states
so uh
it's not staying right uh just they're
going wherever they have friends
yeah any any other illegal immigrants
are now able to be sponsors so
it's kind of a just gonna continue
rolling right through julio this is an
ongoing outrage and travesty and thank
you for being there and reporting it
and